[Music]
hello again everybody is 45 minutes
after the hour this is Roger rot and
you're listening to dead radio the birds
are singing war is raging the enemy is
closing in and it's another beautiful
day in hell for all you grunts out there
in the field and now here's the weather
I'm singing a zombie feeding frenzy in
the West with a Chance of carnage in the
East the dead are growing in number
every day but the good news is they are
getting any deader thankfully it's a
comfortable 78 degrees outside now for
all you noobs here is your tip of the
day you're facing the enemy and the
Horde it doesn't matter which kills you
Last Man Standing wins so use those
zombies to your advantage you know they
do give you those Z mods for a reason
deploy them at any unsuspecting enemy
and watch the zombie buffet begin but
don't get too cocky our enemies have the
same toys
Glenny ho that's it for today we here at
HQ thank you for your service and
remember to tune in tomorrow for our
next tip of the day if you're still
alive frankly it's amazing you survived
this lawn
up next the hottest new reality show two
solid hours of unedited Desperate SOS
calls going unanswered it's not that we
don't care but uh we don't